[Music]
we're all persuading all the time sales
and persuasion
is part of our lives it's like the
weather
no matter what you do you are in sales
i've spent the last 20 years researching
and writing about
two obsessions in my life persuasion and
motivation
persuasion is not some kind of magical
thing that we do to manipulate people
it's not about
tricking people it's actually more
beautiful than that
[Music]
whether you are an entrepreneur trying
to raise money whether you're an
employee trying to convince your boss
whether you're a parent trying to
persuade your kid i'm going to show you
how to do that
this approach is built on science i want
to show you
how our brains work there's a lot of
research on the mimicry
waiters and waitresses who repeated the
order back word for word
earned 70 percent more tips
mimic people's language and you'll see a
difference i think a lot of people
approach pitching in the wrong way
two scholars went to a whole set of
hollywood pitch meetings to see what was
effective and what was not if you look
at the research
it is overwhelming the pitches that were
effective
invite the other side in as a
collaborator
period full stop
a cognitive bias is a glitch
in the human mind we all are subject to
it
we have to watch for it because in 99
times out of 100 it's going to lead us
astray
if you think about sales and persuasion
and influence in a fresh way
you can be extraordinarily effective and
do something really important for the
world
other people and ultimately yourself
i'm daniel pink and this is my master
class
[Music]
so
[Music]
you